why is it a bad idea to submit to
screenwriting contests
I think that you need to have a plan so
it's a bad idea when you don't plan it
out I think that contests can be great
and they can be a great way to jump
start your career because granted it's
hard to get a script out there right you
can be querying and you can be
networking you should be doing all of
those things but
when it's a bad idea when you haven't
polished your script enough when you
don't have a plan of action when you're
just targeting really random
competitions and don't have a plan of
action so contests obviously are not a
cheap thing right
it's a lot of submissions that's a lot
of extra money so you need that plan of
action you need to know if your script
will do well in a certain competition
you need to do your research some people
just send out their scripts without
realizing that certain competitions are
really more awarding scripts that are
dramatic and not horror you know so you
need to have a plan of action if you're
writing a very Niche type of script
research the contest that where that
script would do well
and I think that they can do they can do
wonders for your career but you also
need to continue working on it so like
let's say if you submit to a festival
then you should try to attend the
festival and network and meet other
people meet other writers actually do
the job I think that a lot of times
writers just write write and stay in
their own sheltered space hoping things
will happen to them and just like in
stories and the protagonists of the
stories you should take action and not
just wait for things to happen to you
because that's not how writing works you
should be out there you should be
networking you should be attending
festivals submitting to competitions
querying agents and managers and doing
all of the things and taking it as a job
I think that a lot of writers forget
that it is a business you know you need
to treat it as a business if you
actually want a career in writing and
because of that you should be you know
working on all of your marketing
materials for your script and not just
have your script now it is so much more
is expected from you as a writer than
just your script
if you're writing a TV show you're
expected to have a show Bible and a
pitch deck you are expected to have a
log line you're expected to have a
selling synopsis uh elevator pitch a
five minute pitch all of these materials
that you should already have ready when
you submit to a competition or query
someone because nobody will wait for you
to go write them once they show interest
so let's say you send a query you know
to a manager or an agent and they write
back you know sometimes you send 100
queries and you only hear from three
people and that's actually a great
number but if you hear back and someone
shows interest in your script you should
have all of these things ready because
they're not gonna wait you know four
months for you to go write a show Bible
or a pitch deck you need to show that
you've done your work and also hopefully
have more scripts in your portfolio
because nobody obviously wants to work
with a one-hit wonders though once
you're starting to Market yourself as a
writer that people want to work with one
of the things is having all of these
things ready so people know that they
can trust you that you're someone who's
invested in this as a business has all
of this marketing materials has more
scripts under their belt and is seeing
this as a business you know as a path as
not as a career
do you think it's detrimental sometimes
almost to win a contest and then rest
too much on no pun intended the lawyer
Laurels of that because that you think
okay now I don't have to do any work oh
yeah no I won this that's the worst
thing a writer can do definitely uh a
competition is a stepping stone but it's
not a guaranteed career uh if you win a
contest then grade but that means get to
work you know contact people query
people put that you want the Nickels the
Austin you know put that in the query
reach out to people reach out to the
people from the festival attend the
meetings attend the networking events
keep working keep writing uh maybe that
script you know was your calling card
but you should have others under your
belt maybe that made you kind of quote
quote quote unquote famous for writing
you know dramedies have other dramedies
you know because they're gonna expect
you to have something kind of like in
that area you know so you can show
and then for the screenwriter who's been
rejected from all of them
what should their game plan be maybe go
back to the drawing board maybe con
they're not ready for a contest or
you know I always say that if you're
starting your writing Journey you should
try to submit to the smaller festivals
that offer feedback a lot of them offer
free feedback and when you're starting
you know every penny counts in that
sense and you're just starting you know
to hone your skills and perfect your
script so I think that those are great
kind of like step in Stones so you can
work on your script and then once it's
polished and maybe it's starting to do
well in the smaller ones then you can
submit to the bigger competitions
granted if you've been submitting to the
Nickels year after year and the script
it's just not advancing then stop
submitting that script there perhaps
submit a different one or and that
script either might not be good for that
competition or might just not be what
people are looking for at the time maybe
you can go back to the drawing board
maybe you can put it aside for a little
bit work on something else and then my
inspiration might come to continue
working on it but again you shouldn't
just keep targeting the one script for
10 years years because then you're not
producing anything else right you might
write 20 scripts and only one gets sold
but you need to keep writing if you want
to achieve something also because that
is the way you're honing your skills
right the more you're right the better
you get at it and the more chances you
get to actually have a career in writing
one of the classes that you teach at
UCLA extension is entitled get your
script contest ready what are some of
the biggest misconceptions that new
writers have about entering screenplay
competitions I think that a lot of
writers think that writing a winning a
competition is just an immediate career
starter uh yes that could happen
obviously but competitions are just one
of the many ways that you can have a
career
you know uh you need to do the work you
need to be writing you need to be
marketing yourself you need to be
networking you need to be doing things
that are going to advance your career I
think that that's one of the problems uh
that they could have you know winning a
competition is really hard the amount of
submissions is
insane you know so you need to again
have a plan Target competitions that
where your script could shine so do your
research and know if it's a drama which
competitions you know award dramas and
things like that
but also know that your script might do
well in one but not do well in another
you have to kind of like know what
happens but then
continue working and continue writing
continue submitting to different people
opinions defer maybe the writer who read
your script for one competition just
didn't you know connect with a story but
someone else might connect to it so just
don't just rely on the competitions I
think that that's one of the biggest
things like people think oh it's all
about winning that one competition and
that's the only path ahead because they
don't want to do the work they don't
want to get out there they want to just
write in their own bubble you know and
that's not really how it's working
anymore in the industry
what is networking in this virtual age
especially things are still not really
opened up they may never be in some
Realms I mean networking is still
working in a way obviously might have
changed but in that same sense if you're
not in LA or New York you can still
Network because you can still attend a
lot of like Zoom panels and things like
that I think that networking can be done
in different ways school is a great way
to network because
connecting with your peers and with your
teachers is a great way to kind of build
that Network to help each other succeed
and get ahead a lot of the people that I
work with today we all came up from like
grad school together we worked on so
many projects together that's how we
hone our skills and if we have something
happening those are the people we call
you know to come along and kind of keep
going with us you know and we help each
other out the same with teachers you
know you might not be necessarily
working with your teacher right away but
they can be a great reference you know
if you need a letter for getting an
internship or something like that you
know I've written a lot of that for some
students you know because I see their
working class and when they reach out to
me like hey I'm trying to get this job
or this internship do you think you
could write me a letter I obviously do
that because we connected in class and
they showed that they really wanted you
know
uh working on instead is another amazing
way of networking uh being a PA on set
you get to understand how things work
from the inside you get to connect with
people especially if you want to work in
television working as a PA is kind of
like one way into the things and maybe
potentially a writer's assistant job or
things like that or just understanding
how things work from the inside outsole
helps your writing uh attending
festivals attending all of like you know
the actual in-person events that are
opening up more these days uh that's a
great way to connect with others
um film markets and things like that
writing workshops there's a lot even
groups on Facebook you know
screenwriting groups where you can meet
other people a lot of them do you know
live readings of scripts and things like
that or there's so many channels and
things that just connect you with other
people in the industry that I think all
of those and you shouldn't just be
targeting one of them you should try to
do as much as possible to network but
that's one of the ways to really get
ahead